the Instagram live video that happened over the
weekend appears to show John Moran flashing a
gun while inside a vehicle of course it wasn't
that long ago just back in March that the NBA had
suspended John Moran for eight games after another
incident online when he was holding a gun [Music]
the team has now suspended him from all team
activities over the weekend I think everyone
around the league was really stunned because this
just happened about a couple months ago and Adam
Silver met with John Morant and essentially told
him that this cannot happen this should not happen
again and John Morant confessed and was convincing
that he understood the gravity of the mistake
there's a lot of concern again with the grizzies
even internally that this will result in a serious
suspension of course the fear would be a full
season that you would lose him CNN has reached
out to his representative and The Grizzlies and
the NBA for comment on all this I should note